in five four three two one
welcome everybody to another episode of
the genius brain podcast when we talk
about anything and everything
also I [ __ ] your mother oh we have a
we have a very unspecial guest Nick the
ear as per usual are you talking about
my mom I know did your mom said no and I
don't think so I think she'd say yes
well your mom [ __ ] loves me yeah she
does she loves you
your your mom genuinely Shh when she met
you she couldn't stop talking about you
Wow
really yeah and she immediately texted a
group chat that I have with my sisters
and she was like I met David today but I
I already sent pictures to them in that
same thread of you so she doesn't know
she's fantastic
yeah everybody loves me man today I'm
not gonna name drop anybody right now
yes I don't think it's apparently I met
some soft very a huge legend today I had
no idea we can't say his name I don't
think we should welcome buzz cuz I don't
want to say his name because I didn't
know who he was so if it doesn't make
sense for me to such a I knew who he was
and let's just say he is up there in the
jujitsu world Oh brah I was amped and I
was so pissed that I didn't I thought he
was a model he is he is he's so handsome
and he's very well-spoken just - he's
the man dude he's the man you have to
just watch his just watch his technique
videos of him explaining and coaching
I'll dude you'll yeah you'll fall in
love with him even more the guy's a
wizard he's just so so nice like it's
it's weird wooden as a heterosexual male
where I look at a guy and I'm like you
know what dude I'd give it to you just
for a taste I could [ __ ] give it to
you is nothing wrong with that well and
my man the other guest the very
important guest special specialist man
especial what introduce yourself my name
is Brian peri Brian M Perry Matthew
Perry baby also known as mr. Weald as I
call it mr. wheels cuz he got the wheels
when he punches you in the face
like I can send him a [ __ ] my man's got
footwork and he's the man I feel like
nobody would talk about my footwork if I
was a hundred pounds lighter I think
they still would you know say for sure
well for sure they would I feel like
there's a novelty to be an effect guy
who can move Oh a hundred percent very
cool to watch it's so cool to watch I
think when a fat person hits you in the
face they're almost like you're a lot
faster than I thought you would be yeah
what the [ __ ] is going on it's like you
need to be whatever they see Brian they
go man he could move blood dripping from
their mouth yeah yeah good there may be
a mad when you punch him in the face how
long have you been training
off and on for 10 years so like I
started when I was 20 and then it was
like two years on when you're off two
years on when you're off and then like
and in the last two years have you
always liked boxing um
I for me martial arts was like kind of
like a just like a cool idea and then I
had some stuff happen in my life that
sort of like just motivated me to want
to like give it a go like to read yeah
right so I kind of yeah I mean yeah I
started out boxing for sure and that was
um which is weird cuz my first boxing
coach was actually like a really
successful kickboxer like he wasn't even
a boxer himself that's crazy from
Argentina
and I hit like a professional record of
21 and one but he just really understood
luck
yeah yeah dude this guy like his life
was crazy like his family was a bunch of
super rich lawyers and they owned like a
law firm in Argentina and he's like I
want to be a fighter and they're like
nah like if you're with us like you have
to be a lawyer so he moved to America
and worked as a construction worker
during the day and a bouncer at night
while competing in between those two
jobs and training as a kickboxer and
like he said there was a point where he
was like he was sleeping in like some
sort of confined space like some sort of
like booth or something like like he
didn't have a home he was homeless what
in the world yeah and I don't know like
when I don't know what when the money
started coming if it was from like
fighting or when he opened his own gym
but his spot is over on can I can I call
out it I'll do it
you like yeah yeah so like um his gym is
here in Pasadena
it's called Gauchos Boxing Club oh yeah
on a rail Parkway I saw that on Yelp
yeah yeah
so now now it's predominantly a boxing
gym and he actually he has like he has
like three or four pros fighting out of
there that's amazing yeah like all like
and it's crazy because two of the guys
who were pros started boxing there when
I left
like in 2011 and now that like one of
them became like Golden Glove like champ
but he's not about like he wasn't a
boxer he never competed as a boxer he
just [ __ ] gets it he really gets it
and so that's for sure where my footwork
came from because it was a kickboxing
gym but like kickboxing like like like
low kicks and then a bunch of punching
techniques not like yeah high with like
knees in the clinch and all that and
then from there I trained at a city of
tonk for all you went this idiot on I
did idiot tongue funky and was I excuse
my language but the [ __ ] [ __ ]
guitar that plays in the back as they do
muy Thai you know the wide crew baby
yeah that's what that's called - it
might stab you for saying that gunfight
[ __ ] yeah yeah no it is it is not the
most fun music to listen to white it
just sounds it literally sounds like a
Japanese grandma being [ __ ] the [ __ ]
boxes you don't know that that's
actually what it is you ready for the
match
[Music]
[Laughter]
three different women at the same time
that is again I don't I don't like that
noise at all but I feel I'm very much
like imagine if they did that [ __ ]
without it I feel like the sport would
blow bigger yeah in America but I but in
is it kind of like in Muay Thai like
sumo like sumo is very it's is
ritualistic it's actually a religious
thing you know so they have like I don't
know I don't want to call him a shaman
but you know the person that comes out
and like a religious experience or
Shinto Shinto priest or something like
that yeah and he does like the whole
ritual thing I wonder if that's like the
same thing for Thai I think so
well it's like it's like it's like their
national sport you know it's kind of
like like to me when I see when I see
like the two fighters doing white crew
paying respect to their coaches it's
kinda it kind of reminds me of like when
we do the national anthem before like a
base I just disrespected a whole country
excuse me I just I had no [ __ ] night
that's ignorant now you know that that's
Russia kind of something so next time
you're in Thailand they're gonna have
the elephants and just trample you I
like Thai Thai fighters though like they
don't change it on paper I don't think
but their last name will become the name
of their gym yeah Oh like blue cow his
cow Bancha mech that was like that was
the name of his gym yeah what the [ __ ] I
had no idea
sorry chatri said your tongue yeah the
president of one Fc
that's why they have crazy names because
it's all the names of like whoever
started their gym the original the
original guy who started the city of
song who is your homie from what's
called the the clothing company no
Spencer yo calm yeah like that his last
name isn't yo Cal yeah it's they change
it because he fights under yo cow
that motherfucker's a bt super young -
he's beasty dude that fool just knocked
the [ __ ] out of somebody TKO somebody
with body shots on his last match bro
he's like violent yeah watch when you
watch those guys train there's certain
like some high level muy Thai guys when
you see them cracked up pads and you see
them trained in general oh dude it's so
violent I want no part of that
they keep balance so well I don't know
but I'm gonna buy a gun I know that
that's what you crazy silly it's so
crazy how violent their hits are I think
cuz cuz Liam also trains out of yo car
now oh the most violent pad hitter ever
dude they're all violent over there did
you see his last match Oh bro it was
such a back-and-forth battle I I
couldn't believe well first of all it's
about Liam Harrison yeah I don't
remember I don't
I only know Liam but I don't know too
much about Muay Thai like the other guy
I only looked up his pedigree about how
dope he was after but he was standing
like he was taking those legs like
nothing they were going back and forth
and just dropping each other it was a
crazy fire it was [ __ ] insane and
Liam has like low kick finishes yeah a
bunch yeah yeah yeah and he was throwing
like three four at a time
oh yeah he's just checking them and they
just look at him in his eyes like crazy
bro those guys are insane I wanna know I
want you to fight one more time now dude
I just need once no I don't have it in
me you know what dude you are such trash
you just do I just need you what if I
gave you 5 whole dollars then yeah
earlier 5 whole dollars is 26 cents ok
cuz pay for my medicals would be Oh five
dollars I want you to fight somebody
with zero fights on their back dude I'll
still probably get mopped up I also
probably dusted you should have never
quit you would have been you'll see well
champion Yeah right gust of wind gives
me a concussion you know that [ __ ]
that paper that you use on toilet paper
I want toilets hello everybody this
podcast is brought to you by skill share
oh yes skill sure I'm talking about a
digital library full of teachings
teachers and on top of that my friends
most importantly knowledge that you need
and want my friends Skillshare is an
online learning community with
amazing classes covering dozens of
creative and entrepreneurial skills you
can take classes in everything from
photography and creative writing to
design productivity and more so whether
you're returning to a longtime passion
project challenging yourself to get
outside your comfort zone or simply
exploring something new Skillshare has
classes for you for me I love
photography and for obviously as well I
do video editing and Skillshare
basically has all those classes that I
can look back on and if I need to find
out something about the program for
example with like Adobe Premiere I I
always go to Skillshare Skillshare has
great teachers and great lessons and the
great thing about that is and the reason
why I like products like this is because
everybody learns at a different pace so
when I was in college I kind of I guess
you could say this there was a lot of
stuff that I didn't care for that I was
learning but the great thing about
skills sure it's you're learning the
stuff that you want to learn and you're
doing it at your own pace and you had
this library of information that you
could just tap from whenever you want
lifelong learning is something that
you're going to continue for the rest of
your life you'd be surprised
like for me I thought that number one I
didn't like school growing up but it
just it doesn't mean that I don't like
learning and lifelong learning is
something that's very important in skill
sure can really help you out with that
so join the millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today with a
special offer just for my listeners get
two months of Skillshare for free that's
right Skillshare is offering genius
brain listeners two months of unlimited
access to thousands of classes for free
to sign up go to Skillshare comm slash
brain again go to Skillshare dot-com
slash brain to start your two months now
that Skillshare comm slash brain
single-ply did you guys start training
with each other and a fight academy yeah
we started training I think it was over
when we were on Locust I started taking
privates with Nick once a week like yeah
and then he was actually a prime I
you're a problem I first met holding
client that I've had really yeah he was
probably like only pure mint holding I
had one client she had two Sanko he
wherever he's at he's uh he designs
weapons he's a weapons engineer or some
[ __ ]
I might have just made that up he was my
first client and all he wanted to do was
do a little boxing and then we'd do
weights and I had another client and
then Brian was like my third client who
actually was like yo can we just do
mitts and I was like okay so we just did
mitts and that's how we kind of started
we started on pad work network and then
it kind of started from there Mike just
has other people beat up each other up
yeah am i yeah you want to be honest I
think that's that's where I got really
good that's where I got really good I
think I was oh I was decent before but
once I started working with Nick I got
really good well I think for him it was
just the repetitions like that he needed
like some people need structure and they
need like structure repetitions and kind
of like a kind of a path because what we
were doing wasn't necessarily anything
special it just probably just more
structure more and someone where you
could collect kind of bounce off ideas
and game plans off of yeah especially
with like considerations of because when
it comes to fighting like or even
jiu-jitsu or kickboxing or boxing it's
so you're in your own head all the time
for sure and then as soon as you get to
when you have someone like being I'm
gonna watch you move and then watch you
spar and kickbox whatever it's important
that they give you feedback and
sometimes you don't it's something
that's almost like obvious but until
that person says it it doesn't click
yeah yeah yeah you know and I think
that's important it's important part
just that's just coaching in general
like you could say the same thing about
like strength training like you know
some people may not know they're doing
you know something wrong until someone
else sees it from an outside perspective
so it's pretty much like you just needed
somewhere to kind of point it you know
like the hard part for a lot of people
is that they they kind of they live in
their own delusion a lot and it's yeah
and it's not even just we're just
talking about that today yeah it's it's
very weird when you people are very good
at gassing themselves up yeah you know
and I think a lot more the opposite oh
whether they're just like I ain't [ __ ]
y'all got anything in me
yeah but then other people are like dude
you're so much better than you think
yeah you know it's too much humility
it's yeah it's kind of odd like where I
think like the the the thing that I
always saw continuously was from people
they go oh I've trained two three years
four years
right and then you see them and you're
like but where where you know and it was
a cardio kickboxing class Billy Blanks
yeah Bo and so but you know the way
people market stuff to them too is also
partially not their fault because
they're totally oh I'm going to teach
you how to fight and it's cardio
kickboxing yeah you know so they don't
they're not really working systems of
actually having somebody in front of
them and exchanging blows they're doing
pads and I'll be it sometimes they look
great on pads but you put a person in
front of them and it's a completely
different story
yeah it just right out the [ __ ]
window okay so you've never actually
exchanged fists with somebody you maybe
hit the bag a lot you did a lot of
cardio kickboxing but they live in this
world where they're like well I could do
that that means I can do that to your
face yeah you got a touch him first
exactly you got to make sure that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] goes to their head and
that was something really important when
I was like coaching people that just
wanted to learn like I had to explain to
them like just with a certain style of
mitt holding that I would do with people
I would make them feel very reactive so
it's it's kind of like your people are
throwing punches at you or being able to
respond to footwork to a point where
people would realize like oh [ __ ] like
if you want to hit me right there you
could have hit me without me having to
throw a punch but it just all needed the
messaging and like kind of being very
explicit with kind of what you want to
get across when you're train with these
people yeah because a lot of times
people will hold mitts and hit mitts and
their technique is garbage mm-hm it's
really bad and that tends to one leg
translates yeah it translates across the
board whether like even if you're doing
a recreationally and you just wanted to
hit pads and stuff like that like you
keep punching like that you're gonna
[ __ ] you're gonna suck your shoulders
up you're gonna [ __ ] your elbows out
whatever right and then if you want to
start fighting oh dude you're you're
even farther about it yeah you know so
it's like it's it's kind of tough to
kind of manage that with certain people
and and it just it's all about how you
message it to your to the person that
you're training with or whatever
especially when you're selling training
to people as a gym or as a coach it's
it's really important that you have to
kind of be very clear and abrupt because
like you said when people will start
training they act like oh man I'm
[ __ ]
even people that have had fights yeah
where did you fight man
yeah like man like some people are just
so behind that and it's not their fault
it's just you know odd peacocking to
them we're not gonna say names here but
you're gonna know who I'm talking about
there's somebody that we know - well
this [ __ ] just so here's
something that I know about like
fighters right fighters that I know
you'll never steal it is so unassuming
that they're a fighter they'll never
show that their fighter than they would
talk about it because it's just who they
are it's just a part of their life right
like you I don't think I've ever met a
comic that was like oh by the way I do
comedy I'm so funny dude yeah they're
just they're just the guy know and when
they're on stage they do the material
there right but there's somebody that we
know that this [ __ ] just
peacocking all the [ __ ] time
like even when I first met this dude he
was just like just doing random footwork
shadowboxing in front of hey bro what is
going on huh like what is going on like
why's this guy just [ __ ] shadowboxing
in front of my face like what are you
doing pivoting out of the way of nothing
no no this like you joke but it was
serious like you know this is like this
is after he left and I was talking to
him and he was just like telling me all
the stories about he is like X amount of
fights under his belt or whatever and
and it's kind of odd when you see that
and then we kind of later on I looked at
its Instagram and I saw the dude hitting
pads and or just like doing some [ __ ]
and I'm like or even just shadow box
shadow boxing I was like this is odd I
was like you had that many fights under
your belt but you're getting beat up by
the government holder it looks so bad
and so I'm wondering - it's like well
I'm not one to say to say to somebody
like oh I think he's lying right but the
proof is in the pudding especially when
it comes to fighting you can't lie about
stuff yeah dude fighting no it's either
good or not yeah so it's very black and
white it's very black and white that's
like even with jujitsu you can't how can
you lie about your your belt status or
like if an you roll you can't when
somebody grabs you and you're in that
situation the truth is gonna come out
yeah like raises that people do though
in a martial art with a belt system like
a legitimate belt system like jiu-jitsu
and
people will get fake belts that to me
and I'm not even in like the jiu-jitsu
community but just from the outside
looking in like that looks insane yeah
how could you walk into a gym where
nobody knows you and you're like oh yeah
yeah I have this belt but you know it's
crazies that we've all rolled with
people that are a certain belt and in
your head you're like there's no [ __ ]
way
yeah there's no way yeah you know but
then again on the opposite side of the
spectrum you roll with someone that is
you think is say a blue belt like a
super dope Bluebell and you roll with
them and you're like oh you're seven
black belts though yeah okay there's
this one kid his name is Michael gal Val
and he's like 14 and this dude he looks
like a [ __ ] man he's Brazilian and he
sub in like black belts in tournaments
that's frightening nice like grown-ass
man and you're like oh [ __ ] I might as
well just stop doing a head like what am
I gonna do some of these young kids they
just have like a plethora of knowledge
now like a lot of older people didn't
have so like the sport keeps evolving
over and over and over so they're
they're benefiting from everybody else's
fruits the labor which is a great thing
you know so like the stuff that it took
time and repetition for people to learn
now those foundations already set for
them you say the same thing about NBA
right like oh yeah ayan Williams would
be [ __ ] a thing
yeah eighties no bro he's [ __ ] no
smash before I know yeah you probably is
dude he's a baller but a rockets dude I
can't believe they [ __ ] uh the [ __ ]
nut from the Toronto Raptors oh yeah
it's [ __ ] dumbass but blathers I was
like [ __ ] about a ring dude yeah
did you K my boy Jeremy Lin kind of ring
you know what no the memes about that
[ __ ] was hilarious somebody made
a highlight of like him in the series
and they just kept like reverse slow
motion just him like pulling up his
sleeve and I'm like you look at the
score at the bottom and it's like a
hundred thirty to 120 seconds left of
the fourth quarter and he's just like is
he to get subbed in he's just bringing
the ball up and
like oh man that sucks do but when
linsanity was was alive that was for the
fire she one of the most happiest times
in my life I mean he's the way he's like
one of the first like Chinese Americans
to ever get it and be happy right that's
why he's for sure number one right yeah
cuz all day yeah Ming got a ring now he
did it he got means a [ __ ] legend
yeah yeah Ming's a baller don't you ever
disrespect y'all me he gave me flannel
he's tall like one though yeah but then
did you see the UH did you see the
interview with Drake or he's talking
about they interviewed him after Drake
Oh what is what did he say oh dude
[ __ ] no ramoo bro if you could pull it
up or somehow but they they started
interviewing him and they asked him like
you know how do you feel about the the
game we gotta yeah whatever the [ __ ]
interviews you know after a series final
you know what they ask but you could
tell he's [ __ ] out to lunch bro like
he it's one of those things where he's
trying to be he's not trying to be a
regular dude he's trying to be like a
rapper right and they ask him like so
how do you feel about this win and he's
he just goes off on this tangent about
how he's like man Kauai brought a chip
to the city man all I know is I want my
chips with a dip he just keeps saying it
over and over again oh look at where the
interviewers and he's looking over here
you know you know what happened is
because they asked him something about
basketball and he's like [ __ ] I don't
know anything yep just been like you
know three-pointers and free-throws are
you know just [ __ ] obscure about that
last play he goes well you know it was
Shakespearean with it you don't say
again poetry though if I were to ask
your drink and I asked you so Drake how
did you how did you feel about Kauai
performance this series let me tell you
about performance Matt I want I want all
that sauce with my soda yeah when a pop
stuff drop a Mentos in it boom what
Wow Drake that that was actually pretty
accurate of No
touchdown came in though yeah everyone's
in the back and you could tell them what
they're just like they're just looking
straight or not me and it's really
cringe-worthy but it's really fun game
is when they hit that homerun yeah and
he spiked the ball and hit that
touchdown it was my favorite part
they're gonna ask me about football
etics
basketball Drake this podcast is brought
to you by care of care of is a
subscription service that delivers
vitamins and supplements customized for
your specific health needs you take a
short quiz and answer questions about
your diet lifestyle fitness and health
goals and care of put together a
personalized plan just for you now check
this out
get back into a healthy routine give
yourself support the season with a boost
whether you're looking for energy better
sleep or to maintain stress or something
else to help you feel your healthiest
now care of online quiz lets you know
exactly what you need you answer easy
questions like how much sleep are you
getting are you looking for more energy
do you need something to help support
weight management and more taking care
of your health should be easy and
convenient I love the fact that this is
easy and convenient depending on your
personalized care of plan you'll get
daily vitamin packs and/or protein
powder sent right to your door it's cute
is customized the packets even say your
name on them care of make sure that what
you're putting into your body comes from
the best sources backed by honest
guidance and transparency all available
to you on their web site now check this
out
the cool thing about care of
specifically if you are concerned about
your health
let's just not say concern let's say
that health is something that's
important to you care of might be the
thing for you for me I like the fact
that I can get vitamins that I
specifically need and we're not doing
just just the regular blanket
over-the-counter vitamin you're filling
out this quiz they get to know you what
what is
minoritized in your health life and then
you get this personalized stuff it's
super cute and even beyond that it's
great for you my friends so check it out
for 25% off your first care of order go
to take care of dot-com and enter genius
for 25% off your first care of order
make sure you go to take care of dot-com
that's ta ke CA re o F calm and enter
genius for 25% off yes I don't even
follow a basketball like I used to
anymore now nobody has time to watch all
these basketball games yeah I just I
think it's just because I think I
started disliking basketball when
there's just too many trades like you
don't ever get to live with team minutes
players anymore yeah like everybody just
bounces everywhere I'm saying yeah super
teams now who's your team sacrum a
Sacramento Kings today
no more boogie cousins and who do they
have they have the Aaron Fox which he is
a [ __ ] amazing I was hoping Hawaii
should come to Sacramento Kings huh he's
like psych I'd rather go to the Clippers
Aaron Fox baby he's the future [ __ ]
everybody else I don't I don't even know
who that is
like I used to be so on top of
basketball you know that is I'm not that
much on basketball either here like I
barely know my team is he yeah prodigy
well you know what's you know it's also
like really annoying is when I'm talking
to a client and every no matter what
month it is out of the year they're
always saying oh I'm about to go to a
Dodger game today because baseball is
always [ __ ] in season do you like
baseball no it's one of the most first
of all I love America I just want to put
that out Oh baseball's [ __ ] boring as
[ __ ] I don't think any of your viewers
watch baseball
okay great because I look below my bring
this out if I you know what people say
to they go dude watching a baseball game
live is so much better no ill [ __ ]
know what not I just spent a lot of
money on food exactly smashed it and
next thing you know I'm $200 poor yeah
that's $14 suck top yeah I don't get it
like I don't understand why watching
baseball person would be so much better
than watching it at home because when I
watch it at home I could just trough the
TV and it's way better
oh dude watching baseball at home that
never happens
yeah who's watching bait a lot yeah yes
if you're a fan I understand but for me
not dude the one time I went to a Dodger
game I didn't know what the [ __ ] was
going on I don't know what's going I was
just eating hot dogs people people
always ask me about bait I don't [ __ ]
know man they're like you don't you
don't like baseball as I would part
where nothing happens or when nothing
happens right but you know it's crazy
people watch baseball but they won't
watch like glory kickboxing I know yeah
this action constantly yeah
[ __ ] are getting knocked out
and people are just fighting each other
which is I thought it was not I feel
like fighting so relatable yes because
everybody feels like they can do it all
straight [ __ ] everybody every man
every man thinks he can fight every
single man things yeah that's true
don't ever train with nicotine ever get
better don't just come live with me
instead yeah he's taking clients who
want to gain strength and fitness yeah
but you know box is cool I'll just make
Brian hold pads for you why I won't hang
with you use Brian's actually really
good coach too did like when it comes to
kickboxing and boxing thank you yeah
kickboxing and boxing so hard dude
it's really tough it's like if you don't
get the repetition in you just
continually just go this way oh yeah
thank you after two weeks you get back
to where you were maybe before yeah and
then you stopped again then you go all
the way back again here's the thing it's
like yeah you train really hard like for
a couple weeks and then there's this
food show called San Foos [ __ ] New
York for three weeks and then and then
you don't have anywhere to Train and
then you come back and then you just
train over again yeah man and you're
like shadow boxing that whole time if
you wanted yeah but then I got there's
no tennis courts in New York when we
first went when I first went to him dude
I was so about it all the time well he
got so good so quit you Brian knows like
Brian used to see you in the gym when it
first started and then afterwards like
all the time the tail-end and he
actually started training with us a
little more and he saw and everybody
would say like dude David got really
good really quick and it's not necess
you know like if it was basketball you
really want to get [ __ ] better at
basketball he would have done
it was hard it was good because well
during that time too I was going through
like trying to lose weight right and it
was just mainly for like mental health
too like I needed to get my [ __ ]
together because you just want to get
move in - yeah I wanted to be active and
I wanted to keep moving and then with
like the everything goes hand in hand
with the sport like kickboxing or boxing
you can't you can't just go in and hit
pads and expect to get better yes it
doesn't work right and I just never
wanted to come into a session where I
didn't get a little bit better than I
was before or we would just do the same
lesson over and I just I hated that if
it seemed like a waste of time to me
yeah so after we would do waste of money
yeah after I would do a session with him
I go home I would walk to these tennis
courts and I would just practice my
extension just you know do all this
stuff with all this drills I've ever
seen
which apparently I completely forgot you
just don't practice it it just it just
goes out the [ __ ] window you don't
extend out you don't do all this other
stuff like your footwork goes out the
[ __ ] window everything just
disappears and it was repetition
repetition repetition homework homework
homework homework homework and it was it
was so it was fun it's still fun now
it's just now that I'm decided to work
again yeah the repetitions gone now you
have to like work way more that's all it
is and that's the other thing too is
like people get like they get
discouraged when they pick up a new
skill or something like that but it it
applies everywhere and like if you want
to get better at something you have to
reps
you have to put in the reps yeah yeah
but no matter what it is so that's why
you got good so quick and then you kind
of you just kind of let it happen to you
like you just don't eat and you didn't
like look back and you didn't really
question anything either so it was
pretty easy for David to like pick up
what he did but now he questions
everything and I'm like what are we
doing there's a point to like where now
it's just uh I think like it's it's fun
now so now like I I don't take it as
serious as I used to anymore just
because what's the point now well what
am I trying to do here if I if I have a
goal of like okay well I want to beat
this person up really bad then the site
Oh shots fired
starting right absolutely not Bart he
was kicked your ass dude that will hit
me with a full blow you'll clock me at
mcLaughlin David you and Bart at
slam this year you guys my perfect world
at summers total against each other yeah
easy deal but that's what having like
your friends come through like Bart was
doing it at the same time and he was you
know his training method was so
different from March to regimen why
isn't like what he was learning so it
was cool just to come together and see
what we would learn and we would spar in
exchange yeah so that was super which is
really cool because most people don't
have that luxury to kind of like pick up
something like this as like older adults
yeah then just keep training with
everybody and have like a community
where you train with especially for like
kickboxing you know yeah yeah so it's
it's it's very unique so that's really
cool that you guys are able to do that
cuz Ron is a [ __ ] scary man I know
and he's and like you said earlier about
fighters how you wouldn't even know he's
a professional fighter
you would never know he's the sweetest
man on earth yeah until he elbows you to
an oblivion yeah and yeah and then you
have cuts all over your face and yeah
cuz Ron the smiley guys is like hey
what's up Ron is such a [ __ ] beast
though dude he's like I've never I've
never seen somebody who likes to fight
as much as him like he [ __ ] lives and
breathe session like he can't wait to
get it like he's so he was I think he
was inactive for four to four to five
years or so but now he's like he's had
like more professional fights than
mostly anybody in his gym in this year
alone yeah oh yes he's just back at it
again dude he did three this year he did
three this year already yeah almost like
month like back to back to back boxing
kickboxing he did which I and to MMA
whoa yeah knocked out the second match
he knocked out the guy in like 33
seconds he technically knocked him out
to the first thirty seconds yeah but
then he just got caught at the end yeah
just one little missed happens whatever
screws knocked off the ring rust it's
[ __ ] crazy man that's always tell
like when people they I think when they
come in to train like a martial art I
think you just have to focus about what
what you want out of it right like if
you want to you have to be very clear in
your expectations and your goals big
time yeah and when it comes anything but
that has to be very clear because I'll
have people that will come to me and
they'll say I want to get in shape by
doing boxing and I'm like alright yeah
what kind of shape well you that's me
that even what they determine as in Shea
right has to be very clear yeah you know
and it's like okay is this the best mode
for you to do that do that yeah probably
yeah maybe but you know for a private
lesson that's you know yes that might be
a little different might want to join a
class or join as like a yeah if it's
just for like fitness purposes then you
might as well just join a class join a
class because there's they'll work you
to death oh yeah because that's the I
think like the class part was an
interesting for me because I've taken
like kickboxing classes and you don't
really learn anything you're just
they're just the sweat you're [ __ ] it
yeah yeah you know it's one thing if you
want to learn like technique yeah and
you want to learn how to do it the right
way and make it look as pretty much the
best way possible then yeah I'd say yeah
find a coach find someone that could
really teach you that style and and get
what you need because there's a lot of
coaches that offer different you know
services but for the most part do just
join a gym join a class join something
there's so many good gyms that nowadays
do there's so many gyms you go to where
you could learn the actual skills and
get a good workout in and I think like
kickboxing or boxing or Muay Thai it
thrives in like a community environment
yeah like if you really want to learn
how to you know like you need a lot of
people to train with you need gotta get
different looks every day yeah you need
that it's it's different looks
so I'd always tell people like dude just
go to a gym find someone that is a good
coach that can show you the art the
right way just sometimes people smell
yeah so stinky like you know wrong you
didn't shower today sir yeah we know
summer and [ __ ] once again we were
talking about this today we know some
people that you could smell them a room
away that's [ __ ] up and you're like or
or you walk into the room and they're
not there anymore but you're like oh he
this person was here so [ __ ] them he was
in this area if I had if I had a gym my
my prerequisite is it before you roll
before you spar you need to have bathe
yourself yeah because it's not fair it's
almost like having a third arm
it's like who's punching me upside my
head oh that's right it's turf I see on
camera like when I first started
training I we would do clenching right
now wait i plumb oh and like that was
cool I would train with a lot of
different people and then there was just
one dude that's stunk
oh no and you'd grapple with him once
and you're like oh I smell like him
that's rude as [ __ ] oh my god so he's
not like him all day
dad even with soap and water no dude no
like it penetrates no sighs just don't
bathe themselves yeah and it's like
that's like months oh dude it's bad but
like really bad
a shower this morning that's yeah and
and like you other people may not smell
it but you smell it that's son there's
there's somebody that I know that it's
so funny because you know I think like I
grew up in a culture where we just like
clown on each other all the time right
so we always just make fun of people or
whatever
but like I remember we were sitting
around and I was just like hey guys so
we need to talk to this dude
specifically because I'm not trying to
make fun of him like this is this beyond
jokes no he [ __ ] smells like it within
that within my group not really close to
him you know I'm like the guy that's
just kind of like nothing close this guy
just like yo you guys should say
something yeah like don't just let him
walk around smelling like ass you know
like let him know hey bro you know what
a open butthole smells like you that's
your whole body yeah baby yourself
because I think as a friend you should
let somebody know when they're just
obliterating my senses of smell like
sure you knows how many missed
opportunities that person have for sure
oh yeah nobody wants to be around some
that smells oh yeah and I'm telling you
I'm like dude this guy [ __ ] stinks
maybe I should let him [ __ ] know I
can't find a significant other Oh
probably hard for him to get a new job
you know like he's probably hard to make
friends it's just hard like being around
people who smell man like I understand
well I'm not talking about cultural
smell you that I'm not talking about
people who smell like you know Asian
people we got that mothball smell
whatever that's fine that's like that's
a cultural and then you eventually get
used to it yeah I'm talking about
[ __ ] Bo like like bad health yeah
yeah edgy like ass yeah like babe
yourself disgusting [ __ ] like if you get
an open wound it's getting staff
immediately yeah
I was asked if I'm like do I smell
please tell me if I smell please only
and then she's like now you know smile
all right cool
I just wish I didn't sweat so much I
[ __ ] sweat too much that's my thing
I sweat like an [ __ ] dude well I
think all three of us we sweat probably
I've seen you sweat Oh crazy
Brian sweats like crazy I sweat like
crazy
Bart probably switch to most animals
though that full sweats before you start
yeah well cuz he's always just like
lifting so much weight he's just hot all
the time yeah he runs hot
I think Taiwanese people do run hot it's
just the [ __ ] culture and the weather
culture definitely it's like an
adaptation you know you're ready to just
sweat through anything like if I'm
sitting in a car for when I used to
drive my Miata mm-hmm the a/c was
obviously [ __ ] me not optimal right
that car was just not optimal for any
private e-except just like when cars
wouldn't see you and they'd swerve into
you and then you'd swerve away
that's the only thing Miatas are optimal
and the a/c was like the a/c vent was
like this Jesus Christ dude it was that
big so like yeah it was like that much
air going this Miata was so small if I
farted in it it would shatter if I hit
you with my Miata I would have just like
rolled your ankle me I hated that car
and this is coming from a man who owns a
Honda Element like how much whoa dude no
but um yeah so was I gonna say oh yeah
dude
I would sweat in that car like no other
I would drive maybe a mile and I would
just be sweating how would you and tip
go on date she would you know what she
was a trooper bro like she she hung in
there for for a while that's I know I
gotta [ __ ] marry this woman just
because the Miata was like as the years
went on dude she was like he was just
take my car like that's cuz that car was
hanging by a prayer and a thread oh dude
it was so bad it was like haha man I
can't believe I even drove that I look
back at it sometimes and sometimes I get
in the car some I'd have to start the
car for my mom because it sat at her
place
and I'm just like I can't believe I said
driver Isaac are still around burn it
did people love me yeah some guy offered
me money to buy the car yeah so they
don't have to look at it anything it was
your neighbor
he's like Kenny can i buy this car for
you so I could blow it up car's a piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ] eyesore did not even
that bad dude
I messed up I'm a Honda Element though
baby but did it break down any last week
yes it did okay I [ __ ] fixed it yeah
for $150 that's actually pretty good it
is so cheap yeah man
always so do a Honda specialist my car's
try gonna blow up on the way home for
making fun of your car oh for sure oh
yeah you are
oh you picked him up I'll thank God yeah
dude not at the Miata though right
I didn't oh yeah two other people your
man is so small dude be honest look kind
of cool yeah I mean it was a nice
pockets it was like the poor man [ __ ]
roadster you ever see the givers this
movie called big goober movie no I know
what it is yeah you know macGruber is
right so in this movie it's like the
ongoing joke is that he drives a Miata
and that is one of the funniest things
he's like a secret agent yeah and like
they're trying to amp up the car and he
pulls out of me and it's the funniest
thing ever just because everybody makes
fun of you for driving a Chevy the joke
is the fact that he drives the guy
annoyed sigh coach from my first started
training he was like oh that's a cool
car where'd you get it West Hollywood
yeah I usually care about cars a lot
when I was young I could give a [ __ ]
less about a car now man
like oh yeah it's one of those things
like as long as it gets me to my
destination I'm pretty happy a Tesla
again uh I'm thinking about getting the
model Y but which one is that one that
one's the mid-sized SUV that's gonna
come out
that's this almost the same price as the
model 3 so it's oh it's a new one yeah
so doesn't come out like in a couple
years have you seen the the VW I think
it's a bus the my bus that's the one
that I really want to get but that sure
you're so cool three years from now the
steering wheel is like a rectangle or
tray yeah it's uh that's a Tesla no so
the VW Microbus is gonna come out with
the full electric and it's supposed to
be fully autonomous so it was a camper
whereas
stove inside and everything that's the
car that I really want but it's in three
years and I think that what they're
hoping for is that in three years
autonomous cars aren't gonna be money so
what was supposed to happen is that that
wheel when it goes into a fully
autonomous mode it just goes right into
the dash and it just disappears clay
becomes flush flush with the data you
just sit there Wow when you had the
Tesla how often would you use a self
drive all the time
whatever was on the freeway use it
without fail you did good sketch out no
I used to be scared at first but now I'm
whatever and you have to pay attention
in case like some crazy cars are there
then you hold the wheel but I just let
it happen
oh my god that's why yeah I just case a
crazy me on I just pulled up in front of
you one time this [ __ ] noir this dude
on a motorcycle
I guess cuz they were going in between
lanes and I just had my car on like the
automated thing but I didn't move out of
its way because it was on the auto thing
I was going but the guy just came up but
he [ __ ] smack my my sideview man oh
[ __ ] dawg and then finally like I guess
what a [ __ ] dick he couldn't move
over and so like I was driving that so I
rolled my window I was like yeah what
the [ __ ] bro
he was let's try to [ __ ] get through
I was like bro it's on autopilot I
couldn't move my car even if I didn't
know you were there here's oh [ __ ] my
bad man I was like it's not my bad you
[ __ ] hit my car don't hit don't touch
other people's car man like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I wasn't trying to do that on
purpose and it's like like obviously
you're not gonna squeeze through because
I eventually caught up to you jackass
yeah will he break your [ __ ] but it's
like you know he didn't break my [ __ ] he
just bent in but he just socked it with
his [ __ ] fist and then you're the
dumb part is it's like like I understand
there's a lot of motorcyclists who have
like this this thing goes like that so
Drive yeah defensive driving or some
[ __ ] like that
but at the same time bros like you took
the risk of driving in between range
right dude that's your risk that you
took your I mean it's not illegal but
you're not supposed to do it so if that
[ __ ] happens that's that's just a result
of the game that's the thing you decide
to play so mind you if you were within
alena somebody try to [ __ ] swerve
into you yeah but people can't see you
you're literally coming to a gunfight
with a knife yeah when you have a
motorcycle you're driving on the highway
yeah especially if somebody didn't do it
on purpose like they can't see you
jackass you're going it's not often that
we see somebody fly fly through in
between cars and up in the dotted Lane
like go on it right and just and you
have to you have to understand that
there's a calculator
when you do that for shopping should I
kill you are you insane yeah bro yeah I
want that of my insurance yeah
today on the way over here we saw
someone get hit by a car on the [ __ ]
faker dude dude look like I you turn the
corner and it looked like the got like
the car was making a right turn and the
guy just flew back like that it was like
it was like a really tall pickup truck
so it's like it wasn't even a car that
could hit you at the knee it was it was
the nutty [ __ ] I've ever seen it just
but I'm just saying look when you get
hit by a car it doesn't look that casual
oh for sure only got hit
you're not just [ __ ] on the ground
like oh snap man I was telling this dude
it was like when you when you're under
the rim and you go up for a layup and
someone smacks the ball at her hand
trying to get that insurance money and
like look also none of his homies looked
afraid for him they're just kind of
looking at him like oh snap because he
knew that you can do it yeah come on
they knew it was oh that's why you need
a dashcam people yeah I would have
man if I saw when I walked up I saw that
sir you're faking it yeah exactly yeah
and people are people I mentioned this
to where my girlfriend had that same
situation where that person was faking
it got hit by her while she was going in
and then like the cop wasn't buying it
you know he's like this is so stupid
like you there's no [ __ ] way cuz you
know he got up he was like fine whatever
and they're all sudden he's like you
know and accomplished your sight hmm I
don't think so I hit a cyclist once of
course you would Asian yeah what am i
oughtta if I didn't hit him but he ran
into my car
no one pretty sure what happens that
your car fell apart when hit the bus
bike just went right through cut my car
in half just okay what the hell happened
was it what's the do you plan on getting
another car sir yeah probably but the
thing about that Miata was cool is I
would use my feet she's just like
running all the way through what's the
next car you want probably I don't know
Honda HRV huh not even dude it's all
wheel drive now I don't even know what
kind of car I mean I kinda just want to
ride a scooter around I want to write a
[ __ ] one of those birds so I do you
want me to never respect you have you
ever ridden one they're so cool not
right now never write that [ __ ] dude
come on man why don't you just superglue
the dick your dick to your [ __ ] and
just have a [ __ ] mad [ __ ] [ __ ] would
you will have a [ __ ] scooter because
it won't reach that far first it have a
scooter and a car oh you just want a
scooter nah obviously joking but you
want a smart car is what you want
what would be an upgrade beginning a
Miata or a smart car you might as once
you get a smart car yeah I just get a
smart guy you mean just like a golf cart
with windows yeah at least you're not
pay for gas I can't like I told you I
like I like those little Lexus uh dude
don't even you like the smallest car I'd
like small carts you like these smallest
cars on earth dude this parking is
always easy to find you should get a
Mini Cooper oh dude
yes have you seen the Italian Job come
on you know what i-i've been inside a
Mini Cooper and it's actually kind of
comfortable I make fun of people that
drive me but Alexis though is not
comfortable at all well you're a giant
man I'm [ __ ] 5 2 now the Mini Coopers
actually pretty comfortable though the
small one like you could pull it back
lay it down low and then push it all the
way it into their Miata
dude if I get another two-seater Tiffany
will for sure marry me and then divorce
me if this makes sense for you anymore
no for sure I'm definitely gonna do that
you need a get something with decent
trunk space you know what I kind of like
a little Toyota Corollas I kind of like
those all the news it's obviously pretty
dope those are pretty fire the sport
ones whatever you should get that great
gas but they have a hybrid version now I
sound like an old [ __ ] nowadays what we
talked about
welcome to [ __ ] inside our autumn
holy chicken something with a high
really I do want to get a hybrid though
oh for sure I pay out the ass for gas
dude mmm it's insane
IIIi mean I came in for gas anymore
that's why I want get a scooter are you
know about the razor scooter the one
that you push cute
have you seen me jump off a curb with it
it's pretty fire but I feel like if you
if you're an adult and you ride a
scooter then know also what you do is
you ask taller men if they have games on
their phone for sure what kind of games
do you have on there's my man my man you
got Tetris on your phone that's exactly
what I was in when I was in college I
was good I was at Northridge and people
would always ride scooters around to
class and in my head I would be like why
why because I'm walking right next to
you I not I've never seen a scooter go
at distance I walk a dog and it's like a
razor scooter and I'm gonna if it's a
skateboard that's one thing but like
that's those are kind of cool I guess if
it's a bike I get it but a scooter have
you seen a razor school to go downhill
yeah have you seen me roll down a hill
say somewhere the ugly things I've ever
done when I was in a UCI they should
live it next to these you for sure had a
scooter oh student dorms so this dude
named peter dinh he had a razor scooter
which I thought was the stupidest thing
ever
but I was late a couple of times to go
to my [ __ ] I wasn't called for a
[ __ ] final and the bus just wasn't
gonna come in time it was like every ten
minutes or so I was just like okay
that's good I got you on this scooter so
I borrowed a scooter and a 270-pound man
on a scooter just flying down the hill
beard and I made it in time
oh then when you walked up the hill you
just threw the scooter away cuz that
doesn't do any good back for sure I was
pretty [ __ ] fast though dude I
remember I didn't learn how to when I
was like I think I didn't learn how to
ride a bike I was like 13
Oh insane I know don't look at me like
that okay that's right
I didn't learn how to ride a bike tell
us 13 because the reason I know this is
because my grandma got me a scooter for
my 13th birthday and that's how I
learned how to ride a bike do when he
went
what yeah me learning how to like
balance on a scooter kind of translate
that to riding a bike so the theme of
this guy's bike is you know
cross-training is very important I feel
like when I when I would ride when I was
riding that scooter just to get to my
class I swear to God it was just like I
don't like [ __ ] yeah that [ __ ]
virgin just roll down so fast guys only
seen one dick in his life that's this I
don't even know why I rush to go to that
classes I failed it either way I might
as well just not have showed up damn
difference yeah I don't know why I don't
know why I like I didn't give a [ __ ]
about academia but I would always rush
to class if I was late for a test as I
brought you didn't study you're gonna
fail either way to show up late it
doesn't matter dude
that's just your morals or moral compass
here's a good guy dude you know I know
he's just try to cheat yeah usually
worked not me I was got caught do really
yeah I'm not very good cheat he got
caught cheating yeah are you well in
high school not in college college it
was he if you got caught cheating was a
big deal I was so good at cheating since
it was insane like the only time I got
caught cheating was when I was a
freshman and I tried to BS this book
report on it was like Frenette like an
anthropology class or some [ __ ] and the
guy was laughing and he asked me to come
up to him I was like I want you to see
who wrote this book look it was the
professor's name he owes you literally
did not read this book I like to Shea
I'll give you another day to do it so he
gave me another day did we do it what a
scam that guy was and he probably made
you guys buy it all for sure and he just
made a bunch of money off dude oh I had
a film history professor in college I
think PCC and this dude made us buy his
brandy book because all his quizzes had
to be on the online portion what and
this book was I think like $180 Oh a
film history book for $180 makes no sell
forget about it
traditional education is so [ __ ] in
Spanish nonsense yeah look at that you'd
learn nothing from it you're the dumbest
person I know history I know a lot tell
me something about film history right
now it'll blow my [ __ ] mind Nick what
era whatever what era would you
learn about era what era yeah the era
right now that class didn't go that far
okay 30 years ago 400 blows is a French
black-and-white film about a young man
see I'm doing what Drake did the thing
about the chief so poetic about huh yeah
I'm not gonna even try to be us that
because I'd never went to class and I
failed I think I failed the midterm but
I passed class here some funny [ __ ] this
is how much I hate school we were you
know for one of my businesses we're
learning how to make coffee like
espresso because we're using that in our
latte and then the first thing that we
do they gave us this sheet of all the
information and I have such bad habits
of school they're like okay well first
of all everybody was just supposed to
put their name on the paper so they just
know whose paper it is so we want to
lose it and the first thing I did I look
over to see what they're writing and
it's like dude it's just your name you
write your own [ __ ] name you dumbass
and they started writing her and uh are
you writing her name on your [ __ ]
paper bro yeah you says you are a bad
student bad habits dude I [ __ ] hate a
school man but I still Thursday as an
adult I get nightmares of me being late
for school
yeah oh I do too I do too I get those
same dreams hate that number one time I
was pull it was like my senior year at
Northridge and I just was like dude I'm
[ __ ] I hate this place I want to get
out of here hated school I one time I
had a drive all the way to Northridge
from Pasadena to do a final where I had
a juggle that was my final what I had to
juggle I had a juggle I failed miserably
anyway what kind of school what kind of
it was good for motor development so
learning how to - you're the clown
college is what I'm saying right no I
didn't do this College you've got your
red nose minefield anyways the second
part so you went to Clown College when
you told that story nobody the second
part of the finals was me pulling out
different colored rats at a month up but
you failed because there was just only
white rags
rags and then like a dildo attached and
I was like no but yeah I was I was
sitting in I was in the left turn lane
and in my head I was like dude like I
gotta get out of school like what am I
doing here I was like I need a sign like
what the [ __ ] like I shouldn't be in
school right now and then I get
rear-ended boom like oh [ __ ] I get
pulled over and in my head I'm like dude
if that's not a sign I don't know what
is but actually going to school was for
me at least towards the end once I
finished it I was like okay I'm kind of
glad at least you graduate I didn't
graduate
yeah well for you know I just have you
know two letters by my name that slowly
stands for [ __ ] I did not graduate
college at all it was okay College sucks
dude oh for sure sucked I hated it well
you have to you have to really know what
you want and you didn't feel like you
knew what you wanted to do if I could go
back in time I wish that I don't think I
regretted going to college I think that
I regretted not [ __ ] around more in
college hmm
like really phoning it in yeah cuz I
just didn't do [ __ ] I stayed in my in my
apartment or just got drunk that's it by
yourself
yeah but then like that was when I went
out when that drunk by myself you stupid
son of a [ __ ] oh man
but it was like because like when I was
in Riverside I don't want to be there
yeah and I think I saw your side as a
tough place to be [ __ ] my sister went
there you see UCR is the armpit of
Southern California and there are for
sure prostitutes on campus just [ __ ] and
they're called students and teachers and
[ __ ] hated the University of
California Riverside
I got a lot better after they took my
tuition but now it's just they actually
built some decent [ __ ] there but then
Applebee's hated it dude [ __ ] hated
it and then I started having a better
college experience after I left there I
went to Community College cuz you know
you just I'm just like well [ __ ] its
Community College by the way better just
because I don't know like I just I think
I started understanding like how the
education system worked really late in
life like dwara how to be a better
student like how to really play the game
yeah did you know there's something
called the syllabus yeah what is that
they teach this curriculum they tell you
what the curriculum is what its gonna be
I had no idea so that's what the
is Isis sit in class and fidget so much
you see do you think me sitting in this
is like bad fidgeting Isis sit in class
and literally just be like this all
class and not do a [ __ ] thing I tap
on the [ __ ] I tap on the table I'd
flip papers around and I dude I hated
being in class because there were some
teachers I would just sit behind the
desk and just read just say nothing they
would just read they would just read to
us that's [ __ ] and we're in college and
we're paying this is like a core
curricular Club like this is a core
class for your major it is crazy and
this dude he would talked about how he
was tenured and he couldn't get fired he
said that off the top first off I don't
give a [ __ ] yeah we have literally no
powerpoints nothing just he would just
he would actually read that that was
what it was he would read the
powerpoints not put it up but read it
off the piece of paper and then give it
to us at the end of class oh my god dude
I'd [ __ ] blow my process how does
that count
I thought Asian I would it was such a
waste of time Community College one of
the hardest things about Community
College was specifically when there were
certain students like they thought that
they were so much better than the
professor's there that was just kid I
used to call I used to call him actually
this [ __ ]
every [ __ ] time the professor has
sent to say something right you know
he's been like well actually well
actually this is annoying it was like an
English Lit class it was something that
I needed to take the transfer over to
like a university this is after I
dropped out of Riverside and I and I
went to Community College to go back to
Sac State but he was just always
interrupts the professor as he sees me
he goes well actually the information is
Deming and like you could tell the
professor's getting [ __ ] irritated
dude he's like dude just let me teach
the [ __ ] lesson nobody cares he goes
well you know in Mesopotamia when it
came to literature
it's like bro I will [ __ ] slit your
throat shut the [ __ ] up
so I finally one day I [ __ ] his throat
I [ __ ] snapped because I was
because we're just right we're just
trying to get through to the class right
like I paid for this and I just need him
to finish up the lesson so we know what
they study for and this kid just would
not stop rambling you could tell like
the professor's rolling his eyes and I
just looked at the guys like dude shut
the [ __ ] up right whole classes got
[ __ ] quiet I was like bro I'm not
paying money to hear you [ __ ] talk so
shut the [ __ ] up I was like if you say
one more [ __ ] thing i'm just gonna
slap the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of you you
know everybody's just cracking up in the
class because they're so irritated yeah
everyone's like yeah for sure yes and
then the professor goes [ __ ] thank
you he goes if you interrupt me what he
just goes off he's like [ __ ] it we're
all going all-in yeah start going off on
this student just like dude like you owe
me one more [ __ ] time I so he just
starts going off on him and that kiss
from then on just didn't say anything
else and then that day David's never got
his dick sucked more in one day that's
why it's that Professor that dude could
suck a beat
Oh guys that's about an hour in alright
yeah I gotta go I have a client and like
like in half an hour
okay well that's perfect you'll get to
them right on time I don't think I will
I think you will yeah Glendale traffic
is insane not that way no but it's not
insane dude you're [ __ ] dumb yeah I
am okay I'm driving me out of my god
well tell them what they could find you
guys you can find me at make the iran
dot-com Nicky you're on comp Nick
gear.com you can find me at Nick the
Year on Instagram and on YouTube as well
yeah my Instagram is Brian and Perry but
I just a regular ass and I guess
[Laughter]